[موسيقى]
هل اوتوبيس جمهوريه مستقله الاجابه نعم
ولكن في المخيله او في اللاوعي والحقيقه
فانها دوله مفترضه تعيش داخل ضمائرنا
وانها مجرد حي من العاصمه اللتونيه
لكن جمهوريه اذوبيس تعلمنا حب الحياه
وصناعه الجمال والعيش بسلام مع الذات
والاخر في اخوه الانسانيه
نحن اسسنا جمهوريتنا في حقبه تاريخيه من
التغيرات الكبرى اعني حقبه التسعينات
انذاك جمهوريتنا ساعه ان تتبنى طموحات
الفنان والمثقف وسعى كل فنان لبناء هذه
الدوله التي تعتني بطموحاته الفنيه كما
نسعى الى التجديد وطرح الاسئله اين نحن من
الحركه الفنيه
كيرو في احتمال اختفاء جمهوريه اوزوبيس
لكنه احتمال وارد فلا شيء يدوم الى الابد
في هذا العالم اذا قد يطرا ذلك انها مساله
وقت تتوقف علينا وعلى كيفيه اداره العمل
الفني فلو عمد الاباء والمعنيون الى نشر
ثقافه الفن وتلقينهم حب الفن يمكن استمرار
بقاء جمهوريه اوزوبيس للفنانين
[موسيقى]